uno cuando tiene vergüenza tiene que
hacer lo necesario para salir de esa
vergüenza frente a una problemática de
crimen masivo sobre niños sistemática es
decir qué ocurre en todos los países
donde está la iglesia el papa no puede
contestar con un sentimiento de
vergüenza sin proponer alguna respuesta
concreta tiene que ser un poco más
responsable que eso así que además somos
es agua estos crímenes masivos ya se
sabe de manera precisa que existen ya
hubo varias comisiones en el mundo en
australia en el estado de pensilvania en
alemania en irlanda la problemática de
los abusos sexuales sobre menores pero
también adultos y abusos espirituales
como tal es comprobada y masiva dentro
de la iglesia la ventaja de este informe
es que comprueba los hechos de manera
científica gracias a él se sabe que esta
problemática es intrínseca a la iglesia
católica y se sabe también que se
necesitan reformas profundas y serias en
el seno de esta institución y que estas
reformas son las responsabilidades del
papá y se gestó se ventila el hall en
dura responsabilidad
françois devota también se refirió a las
posiciones que hoy por hoy defiende la
iglesia católica en materia de
sexualidad considerando las arcaicas
aseguró que una reforma es necesaria y
la conclusión del set kabul del sad
comisión las conclusiones de este
informe no dejan lugar a dudas se
necesitan reformas sobre el derecho
canónico de la justicia al igual que de
la teología y la teología te dejo una
[__] con grande ley y boxeo magia no se
puede condenar a los divorciados que
vuelven a casarse ni a los homosexuales
por conductas supuestamente inmorales y
mientras tanto dejar ejercer a pastores
pedófilos rápido sin el grupo de
concusión 2 el papa no puede ignorar
esto también hay cuestiones relativas a
la sexualidad que favorecen el riesgo de
abusos sexuales
la iglesia impone una conducta abogando
por la abstinencia que hoy en día no
tiene sentido exclusivo del día me puse
a la evidencia adicción discúlpeme pero
jesús tuvo erecciones y jesús eyaculó en
realidad es algo normal es la vida todos
necesitamos equilibrio sexual y las
posiciones que defiende hoy la iglesia
son arcaicas la
posición
rodri y olvidamos